whether you're new to Animal Crossing or
a veteran we've compiled a list of 13
essential tips that will make Island
living in New Horizons as smooth as
possible here we go number one one day
at a time with Animal Crossing it's
important to take it one day at a time
unlike most games bingeing Animal
Crossing isn't the most efficient way to
progress instead you should check on
your town daily as your island evolves
most major milestones like upgrading
your shop expanding your house and
building the museum don't take effect
until the day after you initiate the
upgrade so be patient number 2 the
shovel volting pole and ladder if you've
played Animal Crossing before you might
be wondering where you can get a shovel
if you're not there are certain tools
you won't be able to get until day two
once you've donated 5 bugs or fish to
Tom Nook blathers will set up a tent on
your island when you first meet the
scholarly owl he will give you a DIY
recipe for a shovel and a vaulting Pole
the vaulting pole will help you traverse
more of the island but you won't be able
to venture up the cliffs until day three
when thomna gives you a DIY recipe for
the collapsible ladder number 3 buy
everything we recommend buying
everything you can from Timmy and Tommy
each day especially if they are offering
something you don't have there are a
couple reasons for this first when you
buy or find a piece of furniture
wallpaper or flooring you don't have
that item automatically gets added to
your catalog this means that you can
order that item once again whenever
you'd like using the Nook stop machine
you can even earn Nick miles for having
lots of items in your catalog which is a
nice bonus second you need to spend your
hard-earned bells at nook's cranny in
order to get the store to upgrade down
the line number 4 wasps shaking trees
may seem like a harmless way to spend
your time an animal crossing new
horizons but occasionally you will
disturb a wasp's nest the first time a
wasp stings you your I will get swollen
the second time you will pass out we
recommend shaking trees with a net
equipped that way if you rattle a nest
or two you can quickly catch the swarm
before you get stung if protecting your
face wasn't a good enough reason to
catch a wasp you can also sell them for
2500 bells each number 5 eat fruit this
time around eating fruit actually has
some uses every time you snack on a
piece of
you'll see this counter go up in the top
right-hand corner each fruit you eat
basically gives you one super-strong
ability like digging up a whole tree or
destroying a rock well we don't
recommend destroying rocks in your town
as they hold key crafting materials as
well as money digging up trees and
replanting them somewhere else is a
great way to rearrange your towns layout
without causing mass deforestation if
you go to a deserted island using a nook
miles ticket you can even swipe a tree
or two there including palm trees to
take home with you
number six non-native fruit speaking of
fruit we don't recommend selling or
snacking on non-native fruit instead you
should plant it any fruit apart from
coconuts that isn't native to your
island will sell for five hundred bells
by planting fruit trees you'll have a
consistent source of income number seven
donate to the museum
whenever you uncover a new fossil or
catch a new insector fish we recommend
donating it to the museum right away if
you want to upgrade blathers tent into
the museum early on the quickest way to
do that is to donate everything you find
and catch number eight hit rocks it
sounds weird but you can hit rocks with
an ax or a shovel to get resources out
of them there's also one random Rock
each day that will eject money when you
hit it so we recommend hitting all your
rocks each day to stock up on resources
and to get some extra cash you need to
hit rocks in quick succession to get
everything out of them so dig two holes
behind you to brace yourself from the
recoil so you don't have to readjust
your position and waste time number nine
talk to your villagers every day they
might give you DIY recipes or random
gifts they'll give you tips or hint at
special npcs who are visiting and
they're also just really cute you can
also get nook miles for talking to and
befriending your neighbors so there's
really no reason not to say hi number 10
visit deserted islands as you play
you'll collect nook miles for doing
everyday tasks and hitting big
milestones you can spend Nuuk miles at
the Nook stop machine and there are a
variety of important items and even
abilities you can only get this way one
of the big ones is a nook miles ticket
which you can use at the airport to
travel to smaller deserted islands these
islands have a ton of natural resources
including weeds if you've run out of
them on your
and you might even run into villagers
there are even rarer islands that are
rife with money-making opportunities
including money rocks and rare bugs
number 11 visit other people's islands
you'll also want to head to the airport
from time to time to visit your friends
islands you can sell your islands fruit
in your friends store provided they have
a different fruit and you can increase
your chance of money-making in the
turn-up trade by checking your friends
turn up prices plus you get note miles
for visiting and hosting other players
number 12 how to crossbreed flowers
there are some insects that only appear
around hybrid flowers like the peacock
butterfly so you'll want to grow some as
soon as you can if you're lucky you
might find someone a deserted island but
they're not too hard to grow either
plant two flowers of the same kind next
to each other and water them and you'll
have a chance of finding a new flower
the next day for example two red tulips
can make black tulips wall red and
yellow tulips make orange tulips and red
and white tulips make pink tulips
experiment with different color combos
to see what rare flowers you get number
13 tarantulas depending on what
hemisphere you're in you may have
encountered a future Angela's by now
they can be a bit intimidating but if
you manage to catch one it sells for
easy 8,000 bells in order to catch one
of these spiders you'll need to ready
your net and creep up to it if it rears
up at you freeze when it relaxes you can
inch closer until you are close enough
to swing your net if you just picked up
Animal Crossing be sure to check out our
day 1 guide and money making tips video
on gamespot comm and YouTube thank you
so much for watching
[Music]